your business is ever-evolving new
products new competition and new
regulations mean you have to continually
adapt policies but do you have the
visibility to track and predict how
those decisions will impact your
business down the line that's where IBM
operational decision manager on cloud
comes in allowing you to view evaluate
update and deploy business decisions
from a simple web browser interface
let's take a look at how you can rapidly
adapt your business policies on the
cloud to remain competitive after you've
logged into operational decision manager
on cloud you can launch the decision
center business console where you can
immediately access business decisions
just click on one to see the releases
within each decision after you select a
release you can see a list of activities
that need to be performed like updating
policies or validating updates updating
a business policy is easy in a rural
editor just create a new rule and track
your changes as you go from their
operational decision manager on cloud
can run simulations showing how that
decision might affect your organization
and you can compare reports for
different simulations side by side once
you're satisfied with the simulation
results you can quickly and easily
approve the changes before deployment
operational decision manager on cloud
lets you test the policy in
pre-production to ensure a sound
decision then you can view a report on
the deployment and you can monitor the
newly deployed decisions in a dedicated
rural execution server console the ODM
on cloud architecture allows you to test
the deployment from a customer point of
view to verify a flawless customer
experience without impacting the in
production applications from here
approvers can approve the new decision
released quickly and you can put the
release into production just as fast by
deploying the test drive then you can
monitor and manage different versions of
the business policy deployed in the
production environment
that's just one way that operational
decision manager on clouds helps you
make informed operational decisions with
the speed and convenience of the cloud
visit us on the web for a free 30-day
trial of IBM operational decision
manager on cloud